today the mat wall show Disney goes into
full-on panic mode after embarrassing
photos leak revealing its wokus remake
yet what they're doing to Snow White is
truly a travesty also a bite
Administration official says that we can
never know who left cocaine in the White
House even though of course we all know
Mike Pence and Tucker Carlson get into a
heated debate about the war in Ukraine
the whole debate centers around a
question at the Mike Pence's of the
world have never really answered namely
why should anyone in America care about
Ukraine in the first place in our daily
cancellation Republican congressman is
condemned by Democrats and Republicans
alike for using the term colored people
but why is that term offensive exactly
we'll talk about all that and more today
on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Matt wall show I've
been away for three weeks approximately
450 years in podcast time working on
some major projects now some who follow
me on Twitter noticed over the past many
days that I have posted a number of
pictures of me out fishing with my kids
and this has led to some scandalous
rumors that I promised major projects
and then just went fishing instead now
it is true that I have done some fishing
but it's also true that I've been
working on other projects not related to
fishing uh we're still not at the point
where we can announce anything about
those projects but I promise you that
you will not be disappointed when that
time comes I can also promise that I
will not have any more extended absences
in the foreseeable future I'm back I'm
not going anywhere whether you like it
or not also for the record I did catch
some really nice fish but that's neither
here nor there now on to the first topic
we'll tackle in my return it's not
necessarily the most important topic but
it is perhaps the most hilarious and so
it wins pride of place
on Friday the Daily Mail obtained and
published what it said were exclusive
photos from the set of Disney's new woke
Snow White live-action remake as we know
Disney is in the process of slowly
cannibalizing itself eating away at its
own legacy until soon mercifully there
will be nothing left they are recreating
all of their own classic films releasing
new lifeless remake versions that are
similar to the old versions except shorn
of all the charm and creativity and
humor and beauty and you know all that
stuff you don't need they ask themselves
hey what would our best films be like if
they didn't have any of the qualities
that made them special they decided to
find out the answer to that question and
the answer is that well all the films
suck apparently and as a result they've
mostly been flops each remake has earned
increasingly diminishing returns and so
Disney responds by frantically blaming
every new failure on racism and bigotry
this is their marketing strategy put out
a crappy movie and then claim that
anyone who doesn't buy a ticket is a
Nazi it was a relatively successful
tactic 10 years ago but there are
diminishing returns for that also
because after all most of us have now
been branded Nazis 99 times over the
100th time doesn't have much impact it's
all kind of sunk cost at this point
and uh if these set photos are any
indication there will be a whole lot of
Nazis refusing to see this movie as well
the Daily Mail reported quote hi ho hi
ho it's off to the job center they go
for the Seven Dwarves have been replaced
by magical creatures for Disney's
live-action remake of Snow White the
character of the fictional princess who
will be played by Rachel zegler in the
film has been pictured for the first
time with her new companions who appear
to be a mix of genders ethnicities and
Heights the actress wearing Snow White's
famous yellow and blue dress in a red
cape is trailed by the group who are
dressed in brightly colored clothes and
carrying work tools they were spotted
shooting scenes in bedfordshire on
Thursday and pictures obtain exclusively
by mail online Disney announced that
magical creatures
would replace these Seven Dwarfs to
avoid reinforcing stereotypes After Game
of Thrones actor Peter Dinklage
criticized the effing backwards story
last year
as we can see in the pictures not only
is Snow White not white but the dwarves
are not dwarves anymore behind the
Hispanic Snow White we see what appears
to be a group of patrons just leaving
the local Renaissance Fair they
certainly don't look anything like
people who get up in the morning and go
work in the mines or work anywhere else
for that matter the seven dwarfs have
become seven unemployed Gypsies and
there appear to be uh only one appears
to be actually only one dwarf in the
bunch because apparently the most
politically correct thing is to take
jobs away from dwarf actors and give
them to regular sized people I would
have thought if anything it would it
would go the other way right in the PC
Snow White everyone should be a dwarf
including Snow White herself
in fact that's a movie I would actually
watch
but these rules aren't for me to make or
understand
Dell mail has a little more information
about this so flaming garbage heap of a
film it says quote co-written by
Barbie's Greta Gerwig the upcoming
adaptation will not feature a prince
charming and will instead focus on a
stronger Snow White who dreams of
becoming a leader Miss zegler previously
addressed reports that the film was
trying to be politically correct
claiming that the story needed
refreshing she said people are making
these jokes about ours being the PC Snow
White yeah it is because it needed that
our version is a refreshing story about
a young woman who has a function Beyond
Someday My Prince Will Come
yes how refreshing how unexpected I mean
can you believe it in this version the
lead character is a strong Kick-Ass
female who don't need no man what a what
a surprising twist
I mean we haven't seen a movie like this
since
literally every other movie that's been
released in the last 15 years a truly
inspired Choice by Disney
only Disney I mean really only Disney
would have the artistic courage to do
the thing that everyone else does and
everyone expects them to do
it's clear that the left is giving up
their morals in any Common Sense there's
no better time to build a daily habit of
prayer meditation building a habit of
prayer can help you cultivate an
attitude of gratitude focusing on what
you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S helps me
maintain a daily prayer routine it can
do the same for you all you got to do is
download the app for free at hello.com
Matt Walsh you can set prayer reminders
track your progress along the way if
you're not sure where to start well how
about checking out father Mike schmitz's
Bible in a year podcast available on the
hollow app for brief Daily Reflections
or you can pray alongside Mark Wahlberg
Jim Caviezel even some world-class
athletes with Hollow you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions using
hello to connect with others who share
your beliefs and values can bring a
sense of belonging support and also
Foster a sense of community which is so
important ultimately we'll learn how we
can become better individuals in spite
of today's broken World As We strive to
become more like Christ in our daily
lives through fasting and giving
download hello.com Matt Walsh and get an
exclusive three months free that's three
months free at hallow.com Matt Walsh
needless to say in reality the true
refreshing spin would be a story where
the lead actress isn't a Flawless
superhuman goddess but is actually a
human being with flaws and weaknesses
and vulnerabilities
that would not only make her relatable
but would help create something that no
major Studio film has had in at least
two decades namely tension and suspense
you know just like the most basic
storytelling ingredients that you need
in every story including fairy tales
but of course these stories don't have
those storytelling ingredients because
the stories are not stories they are
many other things cash grabs leftist
sermons acts of repentance for past sins
reparations virtue signals ESG score
boosters many things
but they're not stories they're not
films they're not art
now when the internet got a hold of
these pictures of snow Latino and the
Seven slovenly hippies the mockery came
fast and hard and hilariously in fact
the mockery was so overwhelming that
Disney panicked and issued a statement
to The Daily Beast claiming the photos
are fake and this prompted a round of
smug fact-checking articles from Outlets
like the AV club which ran cover for
Disney with this headline quote Disney
says obviously fake snow white photos
are fake
the article continues people who love to
be mad and loud on the internet really
do just jump at any possible opportunity
to get really mad and really loud even
opportunities that are very clearly
produced with that exact purpose in mind
case in point if you saw Rachel zegler
trending on Twitter today you might have
been a surprise to pull up an exclusive
Set photo of the actress from Disney's
upcoming Snow White remake zagler's
casting already sparked a limited but
loud backlash from a handful of people
opposed to the casting of a Latina Snow
White but the mixed race and gender
group of dwarves also sparked fresh
backlash from Twitter users like Libs of
tick tock and right-wing commentator
Matt Walsh who threw little temper
tantrums earlier this afternoon a Disney
spokesperson told The Daily Beast quote
the photos are fake and not from our
production we are currently trying to
have the Daily Mail issue a correction
yes well there's one problem about these
fake photos
um the obviously fake photos are
actually real a few hours after issuing
the statement Disney backtrack
backtracked and admitted that they lied
the photos are from the production they
are not fake they just aren't official
meaning that Disney didn't officially
release them which is obviously not the
same thing as being fake this is like if
somebody snaps a picture of me unkempt
and gross looking in sandals and
sweatpants buying diapers from Walmart
at 11 PM and I claim that the pictures
are fake because I didn't officially
pose for them
like that's not how fakeness works
the AV club published this update on
Friday evening
quote after initially telling a Daily
Beast the Snow White set photos were
fake Expo a spokesperson now says the
photos are in fact from the production
but are not official photos we regret
the error and in our mind they still
look pretty fake the following story has
been updated to reflect this fact
now I don't know what's better here the
fact that the outlet tried to save face
by adding that the photos still look
pretty fake whatever that means or that
Disney was so embarrassed by their own
work that they tried to lie and claim
that the pictures aren't real
no that that's that's not from our movie
those are just a bunch of weirdos
walking home from a thrift store
the company will spend hundreds of
millions of dollars producing and
marketing this film and yet they are
ashamed of it
as well they should be
this film we can already tell will be a
travesty like every other Disney remake
it's also an example of actual cultural
appropriation okay so when you hear this
term cultural appropriation you're
wondering what does that look like well
it looks like this it looks like a
Latina Snow White
Snow White is a 19th century German
fairy tale the name Snow White literally
refers to the character's skin color she
is supposed to be white as snow this is
a defining feature of the character
as it was described in the original
Brothers Grim fairy tale reading now
from the original fairy tale this is
what it says
and while she was sewing and looking out
the window at the snow she pricked her
finger with the needle and three drops
of blood fell upon the snow and the red
looked pretty upon the white snow and
she thought to herself wood that I had a
child as white as snow as red as blood
and as black as the wood of the window
frame soon after that she had a little
daughter who was as white as snow and as
red as blood and her hair was as black
as Ebony and she was therefore called
little Snow White
now
it's not as though Disney went searching
for the new Snow White and they
discovered that Rachel zegler was so
compelling such a talented and Powerful
actress that they felt they had no
choice but to cast her in the role like
they had to make an exception because
she's just so good
that's not what happened
no they specifically set out to strip
this character of her whiteness to make
the character not white this is
appropriation it is anti-white racism
yes it is racist to make Snow White not
white because
they are treating the whiteness of the
character as a flaw
that needs to be fixed
the lead actress in the film has even
said as much that they're fixing it
and from there they destroy everything
else that makes the story what it is
everything else that made it resonate
through the decades across the world for
200 years
modern leftists consumed by their own
narcissism come along and declare that
they will improve what human beings have
loved for Generations
and their way of improving it every time
is to Simply dismantle it
this is what they've done to all of
society
Snow White is just the latest
manifestation
and it's not an insignificant
and I'll tell you why because you can
tell a lot about a culture by the
stories that it tells
so what does it say about our culture
that we have no story to tell
we have only the negation of old stories
we don't write new fairy tales we just
throw the old ones in the fire
we pretend like we've created something
new
but all we have done is defaced what is
old
and what is good
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcast